y tiempo de hablar de temas económicos
en france24 y estamos para eso con
daniel hablando que nos va a contar los
detalles de lo más importante de esta
jornada daniela y empezamos hablando de
los precios del café que se han
disparado este año
hola liliana bolio le cuento que en el
mercado de futuros de nueva york los
precios del café arábica han subido un
18 por ciento hasta 151 dólares por
libra y esto se debe a que los grandes
productores están teniendo problemas por
ejemplo la sequía en brasil las
protestas en colombia y la escases de
contenedores en vietnam que produce otro
tipo de grano están originando una caída
en la oferta ya todo eso se suma la
pandemia desde luego el departamento de
agricultura de eeuu espera que este año
la demanda de café supere la producción
por primera vez desde 2017 el consumo
previsto de 165 millones de sacos casi 2
millones más que el año pasado está
relacionado con un cambio de hábito
durante la crisis y es que como hay
menos cafeterías abiertas el número de
hogares que han adquirido sus propias
máquinas de café
se ha incrementado daniela y el gobierno
de brasil sancionó la capitalización de
electoras sí señor el gigante estatal es
la mayor empresa eléctrica de américa
latina y su capitalización podría
suponer ingresos para el estado cercanos
a los 12 mil millones de dólares en lo
que se supone que es el proceso de este
tipo más grande en la historia de brasil
el estado pasará de tener el 51 8% o sea
el control de la compañía al 45% en una
salida a bolsa prevista para inicios de
2022 ya pesar de que perder el control
pues va a ser una realidad el estado
brasileño mantendrá lo que fue
denominado como una acción dorada esto
quiere decir que va a poder tener veto
en las decisiones estratégicas de la
compañía batiera y se disparó la
inflación en eeuu el incremento
acumulado anual hasta junio por lo menos
fue del 54 por ciento el mayor en 13
años según la oficina de estadísticas
laborales en el último año los precios
que más han subido son los
carros usados en casi un 50% la gasolina
en un 45 por ciento y los tiquetes de
avión en un 25 por ciento el repunte de
los precios es la principal amenaza que
ve el mercado de cara a la recuperación
económica y entre los afectados están
las monedas de américa latina que en su
mayoría cerraron con pérdidas del martes
porque el dólar pues está fortaleciendo
daniela y hablamos de la ola de calor en
canadá que ha golpeado a los
agricultores y liliana pues mire la
ciudad de abbott es fuerte en british
columbia ha sido conocida como la
capital de la frambuesa en ese país sin
embargo la provincia entera ha reducido
hasta en un 60% los rendimientos de los
cultivos de esta fruta lo que ha
disparado en un 30% su valor al
consumidor todo por cuenta de una ola de
calor sin precedentes la otra cara de la
moneda son los aranda los arándanos pues
las altas temperaturas hacen que se
dañen más rápido lo que reduce
significativamente su valor escuchamos
mi abuelo ha estado cultivando desde
principios de los 70 y nunca ha visto
algo como esto la fruta que habría sido
comercializable ahora se ha marchitado
también pueden ver que la planta se está
secando y lo estoy vendiendo a un costo
más bajo
y la industria cree que hay que buscar
una solución estructural a este problema
estos eventos no sólo están localizados
en canadá los estamos viendo en todo el
mundo se están volviendo mucho más
extremos y en muchos casos catastróficos
o des ni de nada esto requiere que
examinemos los sistemas agrícolas desde
la seguridad y la soberanía alimentaria
ahora cuéntenos danira como están los
indicadores de la jornada liliana wall
street no le cayeron bien los datos de
inflación y sus principales índices
cerraron en rojo después de dos jornadas
consecutivas marcando récords en américa
latina las bolsas cerraron mixtas con la
segunda jornada positiva para buenos
aires y sao paulo repuntando levemente y
finalizamos con la cita al día 500
millones de euros o casi 600 millones de
dólares esta fue la multa que impuso el
organismo de control antimonopolio de
francia a google por no cumplir con las
órdenes del regulador sobre derechos de
autor de los editores de noticias de ese
país
estas acciones económicas se produce en
medio de una creciente presión sobre las
plataformas en línea como google y
facebook para que compartan sus ingresos
con los medios
graciela por la información de colombia
ya ustedes gracias continúen con más en
france24 punto com